[Musique]
nous retrouvons Véronique prince à les
castongué José Lego bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir On va Nathalie Roy le souligner
plus haut dans l'émission c'est
Véronique presse la deuxième femme à
avoir ce poste de président de
l'Assemblée nationale c'était souligné
et puis là le Parti québécois lui
demande tout de suite une décision en
disant s'il vous plaît faites-moi entrer
jeudi même si on n'a pas prêté serment
on verra ce qu'elle va dire mais d'abord
je vous fais écouter
un représentant de tous les partis sur
cette question du serment au roi et on
revient
on va donc fixer à jeudi matin le moment
où les trois ensemble on va se diriger
vers le salon bleu qu'on va demander d'y
rentrer ça laisse donc une période de
temps pour que la présidente
s'entretienne avec la sergent d'armes
prenne le temps de rédiger une nouvelle
opinion pour renverser celle de son
prédécesseur ou prennent n'importe quel
des solutions qui sont sur la table en
ce moment
moi je pense que quand tu veux changer
une institution faut que tu ailles dans
l'institution pour changer les règles
d'ailleurs je vous confirme qu'on va
déposer ce jeudi notre projet de loi
solidaire pour rendre le serment au roi
facultatif on va prendre nos
responsabilités on va changer les règles
du jeu notre main elle est toujours
tendue vers les trois députés du Parti
québécois si les trois députés pékistes
veulent qu'on dépose une motion pour
faciliter leur entrée l'Assemblée
nationale on est prêt à le faire
nous on est bien ouvert en discuter du
projet de loi très ouvert en discuter on
va l'analyser à son mérite nous ce qu'on
veut c'est qu'il y a minimalement des
auditions j'aimerais ça moi entendre des
constitutionnalismes dire jusqu'à quel
point le Québec peut le faire et nous
face à cela on va faire l'analyse et on
est tout vert effectivement le col
échéant faire avancer qui avec là dessus
Simon Alain barrette nous a dit tout à
l'heure en entrevue que lui ils vont ils
allaient le gouvernement allaient
déposer son projet de loi Véronique donc
ce n'est pas le projet de loi Québec qui
va acheminer mais celui du gouvernement
et dit si les libéraux collaborent c'est
réglé avant Noël
chacun veut être le porteur de ballon
finalement dans ce dossier là parce que
l'opinion publique quand même démontre
qu'un certain momentum effectivement là
est-ce que les libéraux vraiment vont
être pressés de rendre service aux
parties québécois et de les faire entrer
au Salon bleu c'est un petit peu la
question là parce que il y a quand même
la politique là-dedans et pendant ce
temps-là il voit très bien que Paul
Saint-Pierre flamandon est déchiré
déchiré parce que d'un côté ça fait
pratiquement deux ans qu'il est chef
extra parlementaires parce qu'il n'était
pas élu donc pouvait pas au Salon bleu
poser des questions directement à
François Legault et avoir cette
visibilité cette visibilité là puis de
l'autre côté il y a le dicton qui dit
tout ce que vous dites en campagne
électorale va être retenu contre vous et
ce qui est arrivé c'est qu'il y a un
journaliste qui a posé la question après
sa pierre-pflammondon en campagne est-ce
que vous allez prêter au serment au roi
il a dit non
le débat puis après 100 points de presse
on l'a entendu tout ça puis là il vit
avec les conséquences de ça je l'avais
reçu m'avait dit c'est un peu de votre
faute tout ça mais on voit que c'était
payant ça a été payant Alec
ça a été payant parce que pour attirer
l'attention lorsqu'on a seulement trois
députés faut être habile ça prend
beaucoup d'imagination et on a saisi un
dossier intéressant légitime pour
attirer l'attention pendant que on était
dans une période creuse l'Assemblée
nationale le siège pas là je pense qu'on
a pas mal atteint la limite de ce qu'on
pouvait faire comme bien au PQ on
commence la partie où ça commence à être
contre-productif là il y a des gens qui
ont voté pour des députés qu'on veut
donc à l'Assemblée nationale pour voter
des lois pour participer au débat pour
poser des questions et députés seront
pas là on a un peu le problème à
expliquer pourquoi les députés du PQ
depuis la fondation du parti il y avait
pas vraiment de problème à prêter
serment à la reine à l'époque ou au roi
là maintenant c'est un problème qui les
empêche même de s'y aller au point
participeront pas au débat il y a
beaucoup de pékistes qui aiment ça se
débat là mais quand on sort de la base
du PQ là ça roule des yeux dans la
population on se demande où on s'en va
avec ça parce qu'on en fait pas un peu
trop et là je pense qu'au PQ on s'est un
peu peinturer dans le coin mais c'est
sais pas trop comment s'en sortir mais
là on arrive à l'étape où on perd des on
perd le momentum qu'on a créé dans les
premières semaines vous vous êtes trop
comme pas assez là
mais si la loi est José est adopté en 8
jours ils vont entrer en fin janvier
lors de la grosse session
oui oui mais c'est parce que le problème
avec ce scénario là c'est que oui le
gouvernement veut bouger vite Québec
solidaire avait bougé vite mais le Parti
libéral a pas l'air baby pressée donc
lorsque Martin gay dit bon ben nous on
aimerait bien avoir des auditions en
temps des constitutionnalisme elle a
écouté on les a tous entendus on a tout
vu on sait tout la question est simple
est-ce que l'Assemblée nationale peut ou
non s'entendre pour rendre le serment au
roi facultatif pour le retirer
entièrement à mes facultatives donc
respecter la liberté de conscience de
chaque élu comme les deux chartes des
droits donnent cette liberté
fondamentale à tous les citoyens on a le
droit à notre liberté de conscience donc
c'est assez surréaliste là tout tout se
déballeur en ce moment mais je suis
assez d'accord si on se retrouve jeudi
avec un barrage de trois députés du
Parti québécois une serre dame qui
refuse de faire rentrer la nouvelle
présidente qui refuse de dédire la
décision de son prédécesseur François
Paradis je sais pas qui va gagner dans
tout ça dans l'opinion publique
lorsqu'on sait que en quelques jours
normalement ça pourrait être réglé mais
encore une fois le problème c'est que le
Parti libéral semble tenter lui de faire
durer le plaisir ça voudrait dire qu'il
ne les trois ne rentreraient pas fin
janvier là ça commence effectivement
être beaucoup plus compliqué à justifier
très bien bon ben parlons-en de cette
session on va voir le calendrier ce
jardin disait bon il y a le projet de
loi à un Véronique symbolique qui est le
plafonnement de 3% des des tarifs
gouvernementaux il y aura la mise à jour
économique le 8 ça laisse pas beaucoup
de place pour autre chose il dira
d'autres choses il y aura des dépôts
mais rien ne régler en 8 jours bien sûr
non c'est sûr puis de toute façon une
session qui est aussi courte comme ça en
début de mandat c'est plus pour placer
les intentions la vision du ministre
alors ça va être un peu de main par
exemple avec le discours d'ouverture
le spectacle de François Legault comment
comme premier ministre vaut-il justement
laisser sa marque ça va être quoi son
lag parce qu'on n'a pas réellement pu le
voir dans son premier mandat à cause de
la pandémie et je sais que son équipe
est lui-même cette fois-ci sont
principes de le montrer les vont appuyer
sur l'accélérateur parce qu'ils ont
l'impression d'avoir perdu du temps dans
le premier mandat de pas avoir pu
achever accomplir ce qui voulait faire
puis là ben ils ont l'intention de le
faire dans ce monde aussi parce que même
si on pose la question à François Lebeau
voulez-vous venir pour la troisième
mandat qui répond mais ça va dépendre de
ma santé la réalité c'est que c'est dans
ce mandat ou jamais qu'il doit laisser
son collègue et c'est un lait économique
une genre de révolution je dirais
énergétique qu'il veut laisser et demain
il y aura beaucoup de messages en ce
sens dans son discours d'ouverture j'ai
bien l'impression
Alec d'abord c'est ils veulent ça peut
une carte routière de même
mais le danger c'est d'aller dans
beaucoup beaucoup de direction en même
temps puis qu'on en retienne pas grand
chose parce que là si on a en début de
deuxième mandat la volonté d'expliquer
tout ce qu'on va faire pendant le mandat
d'abord ça va être interminable et
ensuite ben on va avoir des bribes à peu
près n'importe quoi mais pas vraiment de
vision cohérente moi j'avais bien aimé
le premier discours d'inaugural de
François Legault celui de 2018 on serait
concentré pas mal il y avait l'économie
rattraper les quarts de richesse avec
l'Ontario l'éducation c'était la
priorité nationale souvenez-vous puis la
santé le reste on avait dit quelques
petits mots mais c'était ça qu'on avait
retenu là si on commence à s'en aller
dans toutes les directions les gens
retiendront rien moi j'espère qu'on va
être capable d'avoir quelque chose de
quand même un peu cohérent demain ce qui
est pas nécessairement évident parce que
plus on s'étire dans le temps donc en
faisant un deuxième mandat plus on
essaie de montrer à tout le monde qu'on
a fait des choses puis là on rappelle
nos Renault notre bilan alors que là on
aimerait savoir où on s'en va avec
quelque chose d'assez succinct d'assez
clair comme pri je m'attends pas
nécessairement à ça mais c'est ce que je
souhaiterais ouais Véronique vous disiez
vous disiez l'équipe de François Hugo
monsieur Lego veut c'est comme
maintenant ou jamais José il faut dire
bon le premier mandat était kidnappé en
partie mais les deuxièmes mandat c'est
souvent plus difficile aussi
oui mais c'est un peu son premier mandat
d'une certaine manière François Legault
si on peut dire à cause justement comme
les a Véronique de la pandémie
Slate a dit le discours inaugural c'est
une feuille de route c'est un GPS mais
il peut y arriver des accidents en cours
de route on peut se perdre des chantiers
il y a des choses qui arrivent qu'on
avait pas planifié là je parle même pas
de l'extrême de la pandémie là mais donc
vous savez la vie politique à sa propre
dynamique il va se passer plein de
choses pendant ce mandala qu'on ne peut
pas prédire en ce moment ce qu'on
comprend c'est que monsieur Legault lui
veut tabler essentiellement sur le
développement économique évidemment
comme d'habitude la transition verte et
essayer de freiner le recul de la langue
française ses déclarations aujourd'hui
et celle du ministre Jean-François
Robert ont été vraiment très fortes là
c'était on s'envoie directement sur les
murs ça recule partout et en même temps
à part la loi 96 de Simon Jalin barrette
on propose pas jusqu'à maintenant en
tout cas de gestes concrets on veut pas
étendre la loi 101 au cégep etc donc moi
j'ai l'impression que oui il y aura une
feuille de route demain mais
où elle mènera le gouvernement dans les
prochains 4 ans ça c'est c'est n'importe
qui peut essayer de deviner mais on peut
pas vraiment le savoir on va donner une
chose si je puis je pense que malgré le
fait que les parties d'opposition sont
face à une majorité très très forte et
que le mode de scrutin les désavantages
etc justement à cause de ça il y a aussi
cette élément là dans les prochaines
quatre années quatre années c'est que je
pense qu'on va en faire à des parties
d'opposition qui malgré tout vont se
montrer très pugnace très imaginatif et
qui vont tout faire pour essayer
d'occuper le terrain politique pas le
choix on le voit avec le serment au roi
mais il va y avoir plein d'autres
dossiers ils vont être obligés d'innover
et on risque d'avoir une dynamique qui
va être différente de celle qu'on a
recrues le soir du 3 octobre on va
écouter monsieur Lego qui a donné son
propre résumé ce matin là-dessus
premièrement on a un défi de transformer
l'économie du Québec en une économie
verte donc relever à la fois le défi de
créer de la richesse éliminer notre
écart de richesse mais aussi éliminer
nos GES ici 2050 le deuxième grand défi
que je vois je suis vraiment ouvert à
toutes les suggestions c'est
d'absolument arrêté le déclin du
français à en particulier à Montréal on
est rendu à moins de 50% de francophones
sur l'île de Montréal on a 48%
voilà donc ça ça fait quoi ce que vous
venez de dire
José vous dites il y a des choses
imprévues aussi en politique puis il
faut gérer l'imprévu et même si on se
prépare beaucoup pour une chose c'est à
gauche tu as à droite que ça arrive là
le bras de fer entre la juge en chef la
Cour du Québec Lucie Rondeau et le
ministre Julien barrette et le Premier
ministre hier à TVA était assez
clairement et envoyer ses messages à la
juge en disant elle va falloir vous
changer
on va écouter le ministre qui vient de
nous parler de ça on revient en parler
je pense que la solution s'apprête ça
serait de prendre un peu de recul de
faire en sorte de revenir au ratios le
fait que les jeux sièges deux jours sur
trois pour nous aider avec les délais on
va prendre le tarequis et moi je suis
ouvert à regarder s'il manque de
ressources je l'ai dit le chou vert à
désigner des juges supplémentaires de
donner un coup de main à la Cour du
Québec
je rappelle que la jugeronto veut que
ces juges sièges non plus deux jours sur
trois mais un jour sur deux donc moins
de journée de cours parce que la
complexité des causes dit-elle ce qui
voudrait dire le besoin de 41 juges pour
garder les délais actuels et le ministre
veut rien savoir Alec est-ce qu'une voie
de sortie qui se dessine on va attendre
le départ de la Morando là je sais pas
quoi dire d'autre
c'est pas des c'est pas deux
personnalités qui ont l'habitude de
reculer Simon Gelin barrette à part
qu'on le force du côté du Premier
ministre c'est vraiment pas le cas dans
ce dossier ici je sais pas où ça s'en va
parce que honnêtement ça fait un peu
pitié là ça fait pitié parce que le
système de justice est un pilier
important de la démocratie les gens ont
droit d'avoir des jugements en temps
opportun puis on a une bataille de coq
l'administration de la justice qui pense
qu'on peut tout faire en bas du Clos
comme si ça fait pas d'importance les
conséquences qu'on prend les décisions
comprendre ce côté de la juge puis il se
mange Alain barrette je pourrais vous
donner quelques juges mais qui dit pas
combien on pourrait est-ce qu'on
pourrait couper la poire en deux en
donner une vingtaine 25 ce moment-là ce
qu'on pourrait revenir à quelque chose
d'un peu plus acceptable du côté de la
juge on le sait pas on ne sait pas parce
qu'il se parle pas ils ont pas l'air à
s'entendre puis tous ceux qui payent
c'est les citoyens alors à un moment
donné il faudrait que quelqu'un prenne
le téléphone puis fasse le premier appel
pour régler ça parce que honnêtement ça
peut pas durer on peut pas avoir des
dizaines et des dizaines d'arêtes Jordan
de cause potentiellement avec des
criminels qui sont remis en liberté
parce qu'on suis pas capable s'entendre
ce serait une aberration alors faut
recommander un des deux décide d'être
l'adulte dans la pièce et appelle
l'autre ils ont assez de s'entendre
ouais Véronique et le Premier ministre
hier je le répète là on a trouvé que
notre collègue pas et il avait
clairement choisi son camp puisque à son
ministre parce que sinon il n'aurait pas
nommé simonge Alain barrette de nouveau
cette année ministre de la justice si
effectivement il pensait qu'il y a un
problème alors lui il a confiance en son
ministre et en ce moment ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est que ils
espèrent qu'il y aura une pression une
pression qui va augmenter encore et
encore sur la juge Rondeau mais cette
pression là ne peut pas venir du
politique puis déjà en ce moment ça va
loin quand même que vous voyez un
ministre commenté une juge qui a déjà
donné des entrevues à ce sujet là
effectivement là normalement il y a une
séparation des pouvoirs qui très clair
entre le politique et judiciaire puis
dans les gouvernements passés les
ministres de la Justice habituellement
faisaient profil bas c'est rare qu'on
faisait des entrevues avec eux c'est
rare qu'on les voyait comme ça alors
claire enfin le gouvernement veut mettre
la pression peut pas trop le faire
lui-même alors il espère que les
citoyens vont le faire que les autres
juges que les pères que le milieu de la
justice il espère donc un espèce de
mouvement qui va faire en sorte que la
juge Rondeau voit se rendre à une
évidence celle à laquelle il souhaite
d'un autre côté c'est toujours un peu
risqué ça peut être dangereux ça parce
que mon ami les projecteurs vont se
retourner c'est déjà en train de se
faire vers le gouvernement aussi de dire
oui mais vous les ressources est-ce que
vous allez augmenter les salaires des
greffières mais où on les augmenter de
10 % la dernière convention collective
10% parce que vous pouvez les augmenter
davantage le Barreau du Québec demande
de doubler le budget de la justice alors
il s'aperçoivent qui ont quand même leur
bout de chemin à faire aussi donc
pression des deux côtés là
le citoyen allait que le disait en bout
de ligne là les délais c'est le citoyen
qui qui est capable José
on a l'impression d'assister une espèce
de négociation c'est de type syndicale
sur la place publique avec une
confrontation verte des gros mots et
dans un milieu où justement il se posait
d'être une séparation des pouvoirs on
est tous posé de voir et d'entendre des
choses comme ça et en bout de piste ben
ce sont de nombreux citoyens qui vont
écoper de ce conflit là de cette
confrontation là donc est-ce que la
confrontation est réelle ce qu'elle va
aller jusqu'à la dernière minute on va
traîner ça jusqu'au départ de la juge
rouleau ou est-ce que derrière le
spectacle de cette négociation à la
syndicale il y aura possibilité quand
même de s'entendre sur un minimum
d'éléments pour le bien public parce
qu'il s'agit du bien public ici il a
bien du public bon ben à suivre et le
bureau du premier ministre va devoir
aussi y voir on imagine Véronique Alex
José merci beaucoup bonne soirée à vous
bonne soirée au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]